hi i'm amy and this is a delicious
french pastry known as a croquembouche
as you can see this is one of the most
beautiful but technical and
labor-intensive desserts around today
i'm gonna attempt to make something that
has never been done before i'm going to
attempt to make a giant doughy cheesy
rich insane looking croquembouche is it
even possible to turn this sweet
delicacy into a savory delight i have no
idea but i'm willing to give it my all
[Music]
so kicking things off i'm going to start
with making my dough recipe we've got
our bread flour instant yeast sugar just
to get the yeast going and salt for
taste so just mix that up until it's
nicely distributed i'm going to pop the
oil in the water which is room temp stir
that all together until we have a nice
shaggy dough so i'm hoping to recreate a
similar look to a traditional
croquembouche but this is going to be
made of bread dough just love the smell
of yeast is that weird so now that's
kind of come together i'll give it a
whiz in the mixer if you don't have a
mixer that's absolutely fine you can
just do it by hand so i'm looking for
the dough to be nice and elastic at this
point warm
lightly flour the surface just so it
doesn't stick but i don't want to add
too much flour because it will change
the ratio of the dough i love needing to
get
any tension
out
you just give the dough
a real good slap then you roll it
forward and then pull it back over
itself so you know your dough is ready
when you can roll it into a ball give it
a bit of a knuckle
and the dimple bounces back
yay
put a little bit of olive oil in this
bowl pop this in here and give it a turn
go your little baby dough ball you have
to nurture it massage it love the dough
and cover this now just prevents it from
drying out and we're going to leave that
somewhere fairly warm to double in size
for about an hour
so now our baby has all grown up it's
time to stuff him with some cheese
oh
look at that flour the surface a little
and then pour her out just for ease i'm
gonna
cut this dough into four and just work
with one quarter at a time roll this
into a sausage nice sausage and then
just chopping it into bite-sized chunks
so i'm gonna take a small chunk of
cheddar i'm using vegan cheddar but you
can use any hard melting cheese that you
like pop it in the middle pinch the
edges to close it like a little tiny
envelope and give it a roll one down
149 to go so this part of the recipe
this is my bread and butter i know how
to make this but all the next steps i
have never done that before so this is
the calm before the storm each of these
are about the size of a ping-pong ball
and i'm stuffing them with about a
teaspoon of cheese i'm leaving about an
inch between each ball because they're
gonna rise okay this is taking a while
but i do have some friends that can help
kelly and mimo
okay you weigh our stuff
wow look at you
well done guys super quick now it's time
to glaze traditionally egg wash is
egg but i'm making a vegan version so
i'm gonna mix almond milk with a touch
of maple syrup give that a whisk with
this teeny
tiny whisk and teeny tiny jug i love
painting so i feel quite at home so far
so good so now these are ready to bake
i'm going to throw them in the oven at
full whack 475 degrees fahrenheit these
are in the oven for about five minutes
they're nice and golden these look
perfect so now we're getting to the
tricky part a traditional croquembouche
has spun sugar all the way around i'm
doing a savory version so i'm gonna try
and recreate that same look with cheese
so to get started with this we're gonna
do a little test so we have these
various different cheeses i don't know
how they're gonna act i'm just gonna
test them and see which is the most
stringy so this is supposed to be a
parmesan parmesan
we're gonna go ahead and do the same
with mozzarella the cheddar shreds okay
i like how this is a
little rainbow of cheese so i'm hoping
that when these are melted i'll be able
to pull them into beautiful ribbons and
wrap them around the tower almost like
wrapping lights around a christmas tree
okay so now we've got all the cheese on
the baking tray we're gonna melt it or
try and melt it we're gonna see what
happens when this goes in the oven
so now my cheese is melting i'm gonna
try and construct a mini tower just to
see what i've got myself in for
[Music]
i think this might be harder than
anticipated i'm hoping that the cheese
will help to glue this together because
at the moment it's not a very stable
structure it works stacking a mini tower
but i'm going to try doing 150 and i
feel like gravity is going to conspire
against me
[Music]
varying degrees of success here this i
can't even take off of the tray this is
just a gluey mess this is
bad you cannot pick this up this one
just
barely even melted it's like retained
all of its structure
the most promising is probably this one
but it's the best of a bad bunch no this
hasn't worked this is just a big sticky
ugly mess so this was a fail it's time
to go back to the drawing board whilst i
was happy with how the dobel's resembled
cream puffs of a traditional
croquembouche i was losing faith in my
ability to pull off the rest of the
elements how are these gonna stack what
can i add to make this taste delicious
also this needs to look amazing i
buckled down and did some research
mocked up a few sketches scanned the
tasty kitchen and came up some new ideas
with a newfound sense of optimism so
instead of melting it to make ribbons
i'm thinking if i melt the cheese and
put it in a piping bag i'll be able to
precisely pipe strands let's try it so
i've got some cheddar here i'm gonna pop
it in the pan and melt it over low heat
i'm hoping it'll turn into like a cheese
fondue situation it's melted well
it's feeling kind of gluey but gluey is
good so i'm going to put this in a
piping bag and test it on a new mini
tower normally i'm used to doing this
with icing but this is my first time
piping cheese let's see if this cheese
can stick two balls together
okay looking promising okay so two have
worked i'm feeling like i should lay it
like bricks
sort of stagger them i'm not an engineer
but i feel like doing it like this will
give it the most structural integrity on
a traditional croquembouche sponge sugar
in addition to being an adhesive adds a
bit of pizzazz a bit of jean sequoia a
little bit of razzle dazzle
no
i'm sorry this is like the ugliest
wedding cake i've ever seen so this
color is kind of cartoonish this looks
like a cheesy nightmare this is not what
we're going for this piping started
promising but
ended in a disaster
this is not the savory croquembouche of
my dreams
okay so i have a new plan and this time
it's gonna work this new plan will
combine style substance function the new
plan is parmesan crisps i feel like
these are going to elevate the whole
look of the tower sprinkle a touch of
parmesan in these mini circles to make
these like lacy crisps i'm just going to
bake these on 350 degrees fahrenheit
just for a couple of minutes until
they're brown around the edges
okay so these look good i'm just gonna
jimmy this under this guy and i feel
like i should be able to manipulate this
into
a nice sort of flower shape just gives
it more texture so cute
i'm just going to keep placing these
around fill in all the gaps i'm liking
the look of this i'm happy with this i
feel like it's not all the way there but
i think this will work on a bigger scale
especially as i'm going to combine it
with two extra ideas that i have so i'm
going to take all of these balls and
attempt to make my giant cheesy
croquembouche
so i'm feeling good about this parmesan
crisp but what is adobo without garlic
butter nothing so i'm going to go ahead
and make the garlic sauce and it's going
to give it a beautiful shine and glisten
as well as make it taste amazing melt
the butter in the pan this may look like
a lot of garlic but once you cook garlic
it goes really sweet and juicy and
caramelized and that'll take out some of
that sharp bite that already smells so
good the more garlic the better you
cannot have enough garlic now the
garlic's nice and cooked out i'm gonna
add a sprinkling of parsley we take this
off the heat stir it in so now this is
ready i'm just gonna pour this in the
jug and this will be our fountain
receptacle and set this aside and build
our tower so i have this cone which i
think will provide the structural
integrity that we need as well as giving
it a harmonious look so i'm going to use
these toothpicks and then pressing the
dough ball on like so oh yeah that works
so my system
is winging it i'm just winging it and
hoping
that it's not going to crumble under the
pressure i'm hoping that i'm not going
to crumble under the pressure it's kind
of like doing a puzzle an edible
delicious puzzle hey and that's our
first row done i feel like i should have
done some more calculations
before starting the build oh no we have
a first casualty the bottom row has
collapsed i think this is a toothpick
issue i think this is an easy solve
i'm just gonna put it back and hope for
the best okay nothing that can't be
solved with the toothpick so this isn't
as easy as it looks i'm actually having
to think about the exact ball to go in
the exact right place it's a bit of a
game of tetris
it's looking so good it's exceeded my
expectations so far i feel like it can
only get better from here so i started
by using these
half toothpicks and then they just kept
falling out so we've gone full whack
with the full length
toothpick and that's working really well
just to keep them nice and stable it
seems to be going to plan i feel like
this is everest and we've nearly reached
the summit i just hope i don't get
altitude poisoning near the top
so close it's really satisfying that the
taller you get the less doubles you need
to complete a roast i would show up to a
party with it with two of these under my
arms keep the party going all night
three or four more rows
this has been a real
journey it's been an exploration of
myself
i've gotten to know my levels of
patience i feel like my energy levels
are waning now i'm gonna have to eat
some dough balls to have the stamina to
finish
[Music]
okay the final rose you think you're
close and then you realize
no you're not actually not that close
there's like 200 balls on this thing but
this is great for any celebrations of
life weddings birthdays anniversaries
the final row the start on top of the
christmas tree
so the assembly is done but we're not
quite finished we're gonna add the
delicious garlic butter and turn this
baby into a flowing fountain of
decadence i'm gonna slowly pour the
butter over the top and hope it gets a
nice even covering i'm nervous because
there's only one chance to do this right
here goes
[Music]
oh
my god
wow
that does look really good i think i'm
gonna go in with a brush and just make
sure everything is nicely coated i feel
like this has gone a lot better than i
anticipated it looks really epic i feel
like i'm in the presence of a great
beauty the mona lisa
the leaning tower of cheese
and it's going to look even better when
i add my cheese crisps
so now we have our parmesan crisps
they're going to go into cute little
flowers and go in all these gaps hey
just folding them up into flowers and
then finding a space on the tower to pop
them in
stay
i'm just gonna go all the way around
decorating wherever there's a space this
is really adding texture which elevates
the whole thing if you have a spare 24
hours i definitely think you should try
this at home so it's really coming
together it is so much better than i
expected i did not know that i was
capable of making this cheesy
croquembouche this has been an adventure
and now the final palm crisp
ta-da
what a beauty i've done it i'm a genius
the first ever savory cheesy
croquembouche i'm so excited to give it
a try so let's see if it tastes as good
as it looks
[Music]
not so good it's like a pizza in a bowl
it's fluffy it's fresh it's garlicky
this dough is perfect it just pulls
right apart and it's so soft inside but
the perfect crunch on the outside and
that garlic butter is just stunning i
almost don't want to eat this because it
just looks so great but i will i'm gonna
bag this up and take it home with me all
the way back to england to share with my
friends there just kidding i'm gonna
share it with all my friends here thanks
so much for watching guys this was so
much fun check me out on buzzfeed uk
i've been amy tasty until next time bye
[Music]
you